uh there is a possible hung jury
in the trial of kim potter i haven't
followed this all that closely i suspect
a lot of people have not followed this
trial all that closely kim potter is the
woman she's a cop who shot a young
career criminal he was young but he was
already a career criminal his name was
dante wright and he was she shot him
while he was resisting arrest wright had
a warrant out for his arrest related to
aggravated armed robbery
for failure to appear in court fleeing
police officers possessing a gun without
a permit he also had a restraining order
out forbidding contact with a woman so
he really
he did a lot despite not being all that
old
so she shot him during this altercation
the complicating factor here is that
potter admitted after she shot him that
she meant to use a taser
she meant to shoot him with a taser she
actually shot him with a gun and then he
got in the car with a so he gets shot he
gets in the car with his girlfriend in
the car and then just drives off and
crashes the car and injures his
girlfriend but apparently that doesn't
bother him all that much it certainly
didn't
i i hope there's a hung jury or i hope
she gets acquitted
i if you this is my this is my meta
legal my meta political analysis here of
you know we're all parsing the law and
what happens if she did this and she
admitted she wanted the taser and this
and that here's my main takeaway
if you're a violent career criminal
resisting arrest
don't be surprised when a cop shoots you
don't
play stupid games win stupid prizes
that's this is really good
advice and i hope that everyone who is
considering becoming a career criminal
and considering resisting arrest listens
to my advice and takes it very much to
heart
if you do that
do not be surprised when a cop shoots
you
you you have been warned don't
don't think that you have not been
warned this christmas give your friends
and family the gift of meat
do it this is great good ranchers
you will be able to get a box of 100
american meat that is steakhouse quality
goodranchers.com they got a variety of
boxes to give to your friends or to try
for yourself giving a gift to numero uno
this season choose the ranchers classic
for the perfect combo of high quality
beef and tender chicken or go with the
cowboy
that way you will have the ultimate
steakhouse experience with black angus
rib eyes wagyu burgers and more get
twenty dollars off and free shipping on
your order with the code knowles
cannonwes at checkout you know
with good ranchers you are not going to
find
this kind of high quality beef
for this price anywhere the value per
penny ratio here is out of control and i
you know for some people you know having
steak it's like a real splurge it
certainly was when i was a kid well good
ranchers makes it such that you can have
beef and steak a little more regularly
really top quality stuff so get your
good rancher's box or gift card today
tis the season for open hearts and full
stomachs give good ranchers with michael
knowles canada wlas for 20 bucks off and
free shipping goodranchers.com slash
knowles use code knowles at checkout to
take advantage of this special christmas
offer chris rock made a good point on
this number of years ago he said look if
if you're really concerned about getting
a beating at the hands of the police
here's some simple advice on how to
avoid that
have you ever been face to face with a
police officer and wondered is he about
to kick my ass well wonder no more if
you follow these easy tips you'll be
fine
first
obey the law
laws were made for a reason think of
them as hints you heard people say man i
wouldn't do that if i was you
well here's some of that
carjacking armed robbery arson selling
drugs buying drugs stabbing shooting you
know you probably won't get your ass
kicked if you just use common sense
if you jump a subway turnstile you might
just get off with a warning from the
police
but if you jump a turnstile carrying a
loaded gun and smoking a joint
we all know what happened to rodney king
but rodney wouldn't have got his ass
kicked if he had just followed this
simple tip
when you see flashing police lights in
your mirror stop immediately
everybody knows
if the police have to come and get you
they're bringing an ass kicking wicket
good advice then good advice now
so
it's sad sad when people die
but
that's that's what's going to happen now
you could ask this question
should the cop
have tased dante wright instead i'm not
so sure by the way tasers don't work
that well
they can be if you don't want to
carry lethal force and you don't want to
have a gun or maybe you're not really
trained in firearms so you don't want to
be
carrying a gun all the time and maybe it
could be taken away from you okay then
you know taser is a good option
but
tasers sometimes don't work you shoot a
taser
you got to hit someone in a right in the
right spot you got to make sure it
catches on to them then it can work very
well but it might not work you only get
one shot so if that shot's
done then you're in then you're in a
quite a bit of trouble
but maybe i mean she intended to shoot
him with the taser then the question
becomes
should you be convicted of a crime and
sent to prison
over
over a mistake she didn't mean to shoot
him with the gun
and should you do that after you've
served a long time as a cop
when you
used more force than you intended to use
on a violent career criminal resisting
arrest
but but maybe not more force than you
could
could have been permitted to use and and
i think not i hope she gets off maybe
she shouldn't be a cop anymore
maybe she should receive some kind of
professional punishment
maybe she should be assigned to desk
duty or kicked off the force maybe but
to send her to prison that's
insane to me that's insane to me in it
and it i think
has much more to do with our idolatry of
violent criminals and our embrace of
insane racial narratives
in america than it does with what this
woman actually did i'm glad you like
that clip
it was one of my favorite clips it was
so i'm glad that you liked i'm glad we
have similar tastes
you got to ring the bell subscribe and
head on over to apple podcast spotify
stitcher google play wherever you get
your audio podcast subscribe to the
michael knowles show
leave a five star review if you wouldn't
mind i'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]